we are less than a day away from a big
block party celebrating one of our
City's historic spots the commercial
center blarty is happening in the plaza
not too far from Sahara and Maryland
Parkway 12
set to attend the event but some
businesses say they haven't been
included on the plans and worry about
what it'll mean for their bottom line
Sasha loft is joining us live tonight
now with more
Denise and Brian you can see organizers
still setting up for what they call the
start of this revitalization project for
this area here near Sahara and Maryland
Parkway almost everyone across the
valley is excited for tomorrow's event
but some businesses we spoke with
tonight shared their concerns
[Music]
revitalizing a piece of Las Vegas
history
set up for the commercial center block
party has been happening all week with
12 000 people expected to attend the
entertainment event featuring dead mouse
and Mix Master Mike of the Beastie Boys
we want to bring back our history and
celebrate Las Vegas it's a celebration
Orleans Square feel differently we're
left out in the whole thing David Jones
manager of sister Kim's kitchen says he
and others in the area feel blocked out
of the event they've actually shut us
off by putting the gate up they claim
that fence coupled with a lack of
advertising will keep both new and
regular customers out and end up hurting
their business we went and doubled up on
our supply of what we normally have
knowing that we could capitalize off of
it and that's not the case now now we
have a bunch of food and we have nothing
to offer Joan says while he's glad to
see more attention here he wishes
storefronts like his were given a better
opportunity to take part I really truly
believe that this could have been a very
good project if it had included everyone
in this latest effort to shine light on
what used to be
now I did reach out to Clark County
after interviewing business owners
earlier today accounting representative
reached out to me about an hour ago and
said they will now be allowing concert
goers into the New Orleans square area
and have resolved the issue at hand
reporting live tonight Sasha Loftus 8
News Now
however there was another concern a lot
of people asked about that's parking
organizers tell Sasha there will be
limited space so they encourage anyone
who can maybe use ride share Services
there will also be police and security
on site to keep those concert goers safe